how do we reconcile the doctrine of predestination
with the doctrine of probation all right let me
say immediately there is no such thing as
the doctrine of predestination in the bible
it is a doctrine among certain churches it is
not a bible doctrine let me make that very clear
predestination is not a bible doctrine or for
ordaining or whatever it make in other words
once in grace always in grace or god shows
you to save and choose others to destroy
let's go to matthew 25 let me let's
reason through the word of god matthew 25
in verse 34 matthew 20 well i'll pray again father
in heaven as i continue let the spirit be with me
and all those listening in jesus name i pray amen
matthew 25 the parable of the sheep and the goats
in verse 3 now the shepherd
sets the sheep on the right hand
and the goats on the left in verse 34 then
shall the king say unto them on his right hand
come me blessed of my father inherit the kingdom
prepared for you from the foundation of the world
what he tells the wicked in verse 40 and 41 is
departs from he cursed into everlasting fire
prepared for the devil and his angels now
let's reason jesus said matthew 25 40 and 41
hell was prepared for the devil and his angels
human beings are not mentioned which means we can
argue that god is always determined that all human
beings would be saved now when you use the word
determined it doesn't mean he decided they'll be
saved contrary to what they want are you following
me it is god has chosen his will is he would love
to serve serve everybody so in that sense there's
a predestination if you want to call it that i
don't like that term at all the bible says in
a second peter chapter 3 verse 9 he god is not
willing that any should perish in first timothy
chapter 2 verse 4 who will have all men to be
saved and to come unto the knowledge of the truth
and so the bible teaches clearly god's will his
desire let me repeat his will is that all people
will be saved so he has chosen us to save us but
we exercise our own minds and so you read ii peter
chapter 2 from verse 4 for if god spared not the
angels that sinned they chose to sing in verse
5 and spared not the old world but save noah the
eighth person a preacher of righteousness bringing
in the flood upon the world of the ungodly so
we go from the angels who fell to those in the
days of noah to those in days of lots and peter
goes through the history and then he tells us
they have forsaken the right way and gone astray
verse 15 of second peter chapter two and so god's
god's choice his will is that everyone would be
saved god has not chosen to save some and destroy
others he doesn't do that god john 3 16 for god
soul of the world the world what does the world
mean everybody that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever what does whosoever mean anyone who
chooses to believe and so predestination is not
a doctrine in in the bible god doesn't choose
to serve to save some and choose to destroy some
people destroy themselves by their choices so
god's desire is to save everyone but he allows us
to express our choices when god made adam and eve
he did not make them to fall he made them to live
in a condition in which he made them they chose to
sin and when contrary to god's will for them jesus
could have chosen to sin but thank god he did not
make that choice we we must live our lives with
the understanding that god wants to save you dr
elisha mccarthy he wants to save jonathan he wants
to see if wiff is listening god wants to save you
that's his original will now will you cooperate
with that will that's the point you see we do not
cooperate with god's original choice he has chosen
you for prisoner's kingdom and so the bible says
hell was prepared for the devil and his angels
not for human beings that tells us clearly god
originally chose all human beings for salvation
but they made the individual choice to go against
god and some will be lost and so jesus prayed in
john 17 12 those that thou gavest me i have kept
and none of them is lost but the son of perdition
meaning judas judas was lost so one save always
is not a bible teaching at all predestination
is not a bible doctrine god does not predestine
some of the salvation and predestined for
damnation no he wants to save everybody but
some of us choose not to be saved you know you
read ezekiel 33 verse 11. say unto them as i
lift the lord i have no pleasure in the wicked
but that the wicked turn from his way and live
turn me turn me from your evil ways for why will
he die says god why are you so determined to die
while i'm so determined to save you but i cannot
force salvation on you why says god will you die
i want you saved why are you
dying people choose death
uh proverbs 8 36 all day that hate me love death
and in that chapter wisdom is personified wisdom
they means christ all they that hate kneel of
death john 3 19 and this is the condemnation that
light is coming to the world and men love darkness
rather than light they love darkness rather than
light that's the problem god has chosen everyone
for salvation but we do not cooperate with his
choice with his will and consequently many will
be lost but there is no such teaching in the bible
as predestination in the sense that god has chosen
john for salvation and jack for damnation that is
not a biblical teaching at all nor is the teaching
once safe always saved that is not biblical
amen amen elder skeet and i i just want to
just want to read ephesians chapter 2 verse 10.
here's what the bible says for we are his that's
god's work created in christ jesus unto good works
which god hath ordained and he should walk
in them right jesus christ died for everyone
so god has ordained all of us he's given us all
the opportunity to run out the life of christ
even if we were to look at romans romans
chapter 8 i know we we love verse 28 where
it says all things work together amen amen
and we know that all things work together
for good to them that believe god and to them
who are the called according to his purpose
verse 29 here's where we get a little trouble
whereas for whom he did for no he did predestin
predestinate to be conformed to the image of his
son that he might be the first born among many
but the question is who did god foreknow every
single one of us every single one of us we're born
exactly and to all of us he gives the
opportunity to accept jesus christ as our
lord and savior and this is how we can begin
to marry the questions that have been asked
because in the beginning we asked what is the
purpose of probation why do we have probation
what is it it's because god wants to give us
a choice to serve him he wants to give us the
choice the question is that you said elder skeet
will we cooperate with god's will and we don't
you